do that
no
you know I don't even care I'm gonna
laugh today I have feelings
God damn it I'm never ever doing
anything ever again because it's not
safe clearly I don't know you get what
I'm trying to say right
and it's not even nearly there's nowhere
near who made that
I love this scream of the camera person
dude that was sick I felt like it was in
the game man
[Music]
I love this the dog is acting like how
dare you say that why would you call me
that
[Music]
why would you say that right it was
wrong with me
oh
be careful when speaking dog to Don they
they might get actually offended this is
just really nice for those of you who
played Ellen ring the story was made by
George R Martin and there was a lot of
discussion and question of what lines
did he actually make or like what work
did he do and I think this settles it
so it's nice to see what he actually did
on the game
took George eight months to write my
classic line
laughs
nice we can I guess congratulations all
nordvpn click linkers in the description
we already know for six billion times
what a VPN does it hides you from people
and protecting you from people spying
and stealing your data now nordvpn is
now more than VPN they introducing a new
really cool feature called threat
protection you can just turn it on you
don't need to be connected to a VPN to
actually use this feature it gives you
another level of protection included in
what's already a really great service so
basically if you ever go on a website
they have a bunch of ads not only are
they super annoying but they can also
sometimes be harmful so if you
accidentally click on one of them you
can mess up your computer so Freight
protection blocks these ads so you don't
have to even look at it they also scan
every single download that you do to
make sure that it doesn't malware so if
someone sends you a suspicious file
great protection will take care of it
also it protects you from websites
collecting data on you and building
profiles it's one of those things that
people tell you they're like you know
all these websites collect data from you
right I'm like yeah right whatever and
then they go well actually you know they
make a ton of money out of you it's like
no I can't do that activate threat
protection I will not let this happen it
protects you from phishing attempts and
giving you a safer cleaner and more
private web experience if you use the
link in the description you get a huge
discount on a two-year plan plus one
month for free you're welcome and you
can try it out for 30 days we're the
money back guarantee so if you don't
like it yeah try it out link a
description you should be using it at
this point
thank you Lord vivam for sponsoring this
video let's go on with it even the
turtle himself did not expect the two of
them are so heavy
why did the horse sound like
jacksepticeye did you hear that
it sounds like he's making Irish noises
you heard it you hear it
hahaha
started okay though I'm sure it's fine I
actually checked it and they're fine my
husky got his nose stuck and I can't
tell if it's real or if you did it for
attention oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's turned off like that I'm in pain
that's fine thank you
[Laughter]
yeah
it's not real is it edited I can't tell
it's really funny I love it
am I watching two fishes having sex
right now is that what's happening
because I've never seen that happening
before and maybe that's it I don't know
maybe that's what they do I don't know
his name oh yes I asked might set to
send some over let's check those out
classic
it's funnier because it's a plug because
you know that he's fine
he's got that extra dampening material
you know
worldless days
[Music]
[Music]
I won't even ask
Jesus Christ so this is where she gets
her inspiration
[Music]
who is that oh Barney
[Music]
not to tell it hey Lisa
all the copyright that much it was that
time I don't even know who that is
what is that
stop
uh no I'm I'm good
oh cute cute looking like a Rooney what
have we got
okay all right
very typical very typical emergency this
is her dream
my son legit shows me these clips and
she's like she looks at me as if it's my
fault that she isn't living this life
like I'm the one stopping her from
having this many pugs
okay I've seen this this is from
Brighton where we live
but I don't know what happens all I know
is the seagulls are mean here
Jesus Christ
man just wanted some fries man but
seagulls said no all right that was in
good Clips March a clip segment over
uh revengeance status a ninja with a
sword a sale uh US Army Special
Operation unit in California do you know
who I am the man is it starting to said
he did not do you know where my family
is the man is when the sergeant said he
did not know the person in ninja car
began to slash at him but at Katana
store the report States adding that the
Sergeant's leg and the phone were stuck
what particular runs for use but for
ineffective they're an effective sir
what do we do the bladder system 911
from someone at the airport saying 26
Special Operation military members were
hunkered down in Anger wondering where
the help is obviously means he cut the
bulla's mid-air projected okay we live
in this strange world I think I was
gonna show this one to Jack
Chris buys is feeding it out to that
four five four down Lane and look at
this pin action oh
some of you like I know some of you
dirty mothers
oh there's got to be some Good Will
Smith memes
happen all the meme accounts were just
exploding everyone just had to be first
making the meme so no making the funny
one a Morrowind edit oh Richard
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now the oh it increased nice
yes
9-1-1
classic meme what mic do you use it
sounds great I'm scared
it sounds great
I never I [ __ ] love fiber optic
cables
someone's getting me out of the pistol
Mamma Mia I am in the pistol job who did
I feel like I definitely seen that River
it's who did poop
he's so cute he's so happy
I love that Great Clip oh I'm not even
trying and then the slightest guy falls
off the balcony original
is he okay he good
pie so I've reacted to this before bro I
have no brain good thing about brain is
he can watch your memes twice and enjoy
them drunk guy falls off about
oh that's a common thing apparently
there's more than one well that was it
for your life you lose really fun I
always enjoy these hope you guys did as
well sorry I've been kind of inactive I
just been really busy yeah it looks like
a Japan movie happening so maybe last
time the office I don't know we'll see
uh See you next time bye bye